hi I'm Martin and I'm going to deploy an
angular app to Google Cloud you will see
every step along the way so you can do
the same and deploy your angular app
anyone on the internet will be able to
use your app and you won't have to
manage any servers let's get
[Music]
started the first step we'll do is to
create an angular app then we'll create
a server side app using nodejs and
express that will serve the angular app
to users and provide an API so the app
can get data from the server and finally
I'll deploy the app to Google
Cloud okay step one uh first off I need
the angular Dev tools installed on my
computer I already do but if you don't
go here to get
them next I will run NG new to create a
default angular project
it will ask me for a project
name I will be asked if I want to use
angular routing so I'll say yes to
that then I'll pick CSS the default uh
styling
Choice it will run for a little bit and
uh create all the files
needed I can now CD to that
directory and run the app from my local
machine
and here it is this is my angular app
great the default angle app is working
all right let's make a small change I
will open the source directory then app
and then app. component.
HTML I will edit this line
here and
save here we see that it was
automatically reloaded in the browser
with a new content excellent so we now
have an environment for local
development including hot module reload
when we save code now let's build the
app for
distribution I press contrl C to get
back my command
prompt then I'll run NG build to build
the app for
deployment
here we see that some files were created
in the dist directory those are the
files that we will deploy to the cloud
later on all right this means that we
are ready for step number two now we
will create a serers side Express app it
will do two things one it will send the
HTML CSS and JavaScript files from the
disc directory to the user's browser uh
so they can run the angular app and two
it will provide a serers side API that
our angular app can call any web app
I've ever built has called an API to
access a database uh or to run other
service side code to create that server
side app I'll go up one directory from
the angular
app then I'll create a new not tojs
app uh this server side app will use the
Express package for handling HTTP
requests so let's install that that if
you prefer another HTTP Library you can
use
that then I will create the file
index.js this uh service code will
initialize Express so it can respond to
incoming HTTP requests and handle Json
data then I will tell Express to serve
files from the disc directory as static
files and not to try to run that code on
the server uh remember that directory
contains the HTML JavaScript and CSS
files uh that are angular app built and
then I'll add code to start the express
server so it listens to incoming HTTP
requests let's add a serverside API that
our angular app can call to get a list
of pirates uh when the app hits this URL
uh this code will run on the
server first it will extract the ID from
the
URL then it will look up the pirate that
has that ID if no pirate was found it
will return a 404 error to the angular
app but if the pirate was found that
Pirates record will be returned uh to
the client in Json
format now in the finished app this get
pirate function would probably look up
pirates in a database but just to get
off the ground quickly let's hardcode
some of my favorite Pirates
[Music]
here
all right the server side code is done
uh let's run it on my machine it's
convenient to have an mpm script for
this so I'll go to package.json for the
server side app and enter this start
command we can use that command
ourselves uh and once we deploy the app
to the Cloud Google will look for the
start command to run it for us I will
also add type module here so that import
statements work the way we expect them
to let's run that start
command all right the server is running
on this port on my local machine uh
let's go there with the
browser very nice our server side up the
angular app files so I'm now running
that app in my
browser now uh let's take a look at that
API I will ask for pirate number three
by entering SL API SL Pirates
sl3 and there it is in Json format uh
the API is ready to be used by our
angular
app but let's move on to the third and
last step we're going to deploy this app
to Google Cloud
first let's create a project in Google
Cloud for our app I'll go to console.
cloud.google.com
then I'll click through here and here I
can click this button to create a new
project if this is my first project on
Google Cloud I will also need to set up
billing we will use cloud run which is
serverless so it has no fixed monthly
cost it will only charge us when our app
is actively creating a response to us
request hm what does that mean well in
this chart are containers listening for
incoming HTP requests for the entirety
of the dark gray bar at the top the blue
bars are requests the green bars show uh
what we're getting build for as you can
see when no blue request is being
processed there's a gap in the green
billing bars we aren't charged for that
time in other words if our app gets
1,000 requests per day and each request
takes 1 second to process we will only
be charged for 1,000 CPU seconds uh not
for 24 hours we may even be charged less
than that actually if some requests
overlap uh like the blue bars in the
graph the first 200,000 CPU seconds each
month are free with Cloud run and
there's also a free tier for memory
usage you can find all the details about
the free tier and the cost if you go up
beyond the free tier here on the cloud
runs uh pricing page in practice uh this
free tier means that none of my
development or testing projects have
cost me anything it's only when I got
serious production level traffic that
I've had to actually pay for cloud run
having said all that for the rest of the
steps in this guide to work you do need
to create your billing account here if
this is your first Google Cloud project
you get a $300 credit
all right now let's get ready to deploy
the angular and express apps to Google
Cloud this is done uh with a g-cloud
command line tool and here are the
installation
instructions I've installed that uh on
that tool on my machine already so I
will now authenticate uh with g-cloud
off login this will give me access to my
projects in Google Cloud
we see here that the g-cloud tool tells
us that we should set our current
project that is a good idea then we
don't won't have to enter our project ID
over and over again uh looks like we
need our project's
ID we can find that here in the cloud
console let's copy that and then I'll
use the g-cloud tool to set our current
default
project
all right let's deploy our app to Cloud
run I'll enter g-cloud run deploy and
what I would like uh the cloud run
service to be called I can have a
multiple Cloud run services in my
project the g-cloud tool will ask me
where their source code is it's in the
current directory so I'll just hit
enter uh then it asks me if I want to
enable some apis in my project uh to
help with security Google requires us to
turn on each API we want to use in our
project I will enter y to enable
them next I get to decide where in the
world this code will run any internet
user will be able to access the app but
it'll be slightly faster for users close
to the location I pick us Central one
sounds good to me so I'll enter
30 next it asks me if I want to create
an artifact register in my project
that's where all the versions of my belt
app will be stored uh making it easy to
roll back to previous version if I need
to uh I accept by hitting why uh this
question will not come up uh next time I
deploy my
app now it asks me about unauthenticated
invocations to my app do I want my
application to be reachable by anyone on
the internet I do so I hit why again
and now it's building and deploying my
app this will take a few minutes so I'll
refill my
capy and I'm back the deployment
succeeded and here it shows me the URL
that our app is served from let's open
that in a
browser look at that there is our
angular app it is now on the public
internet ready for anyone to
use let's also make sure that the server
side API works I'll enter SL API SL
pirate SL2 after the base
URL and there is a pirate record both
the client side angular app and the
server side API now work from the cloud
we've created an angular app created a
serers side nodejs app and deployed them
to Google Cloud for all the world to
enjoy
now there are a few more things you'd
need to make a good web app that's ready
for customers your own domain name a
database and user
authentication let's start with a domain
name the URL that uh Cloud run generated
for us is fine for development and
testing but we' probably want to use our
own domain name uh before we send real
users to our app let's go back to
console. cloud.google.com in our
project I'll click the hamburger menu
and scroll down to serverless and Cloud
run here is our Cloud run service and
any others we may create in the future
if I click the service I get this page
where I can view metrics for it I can
set service level objectives I can check
the logs and so on uh but we want
Integrations right now I'll add an
integration and I'll pick custom domains
here here I'll enter my domain name that
I previously
bought and enable some
apis this will set up a load balancer
that points to my cloud run service it
will also create a certificate so people
can use https when accessing my domain
when the apis have been enabled I'll
click this submit
button after a few minutes it will show
me the DNS changes I will need to make
with my DNS hosting
provider so I did all this for my domain
already and this is what it looks like
when
done uh by the way this load balancer
will carry a fixed monthly cost of about
$20 all right that was the domain name
what about the
database well there are plenty of
choices of databases in Google Cloud if
you prefer relational databases Cloud
SQL is a popular choice uh but there are
others as
well if you like no SQL databases or
document databases you may want to use
fir store instead
by the way I really like fir store
because it's completely serverless so it
has no fixed monthly cost and it comes
with a free tier also it has a client
side API so clients can access the
database directly without any servers
side code if you wish to set it up that
way finally many web applications need
to authenticate their users let's talk
about that it takes a lot of work to
build login functionality yourself and
it's kind of dangerous too uh you might
leave a security hall open I know I've
done that in the past in my hobby
projects to avoid that I prefer using
Firebase authentication it lets users
log in with their existing accounts from
Google Facebook Apple Microsoft and
others or users can create a new account
specifically for your app with their
email and a password they pick Firebase
authentication takes care of it all for
you so there you have it the three steps
to publish your angular app to the world
using Google cloud in my opinion the
best way to build an app is to focus on
your users and what they need don't
waste time on server maintenance
networking scalability and so on Google
knows how to run production web apps at
scale and can take care of that for
you that means that you can launch
version 1.0 of your app sooner and
version 2.0 of your app will be able to
serve thousands or millions of users
because it runs on Google
infrastructure thank you for watching if
you have any questions please enter them
in the comments also let me know if
there are any other sess topics that
you'd like to hear about in future
episodes I read every single comment I
can't wait to see what you build until
next
time
[Music]
oh